before you witness the ex pocalypse
experience the definitive version of the
ex man as long as you grew up in the 90s
look what you did to the VCR just by
touching it x-men the animated series
return to the era of super soakers and
pizza bagels in a decade where no one
gave a crap about the Avengers for the
first comic adaptation to combine quips
and bright colors with depth and high
stakes all wrapped up in a theme song
it's been stuck in your head for decades
seriously if Professor X was real oh it
hears but a Nenana sued up with an x-men
team you're pretty damn familiar with by
now who are all pretty much the same as
their movie counterparts except the
spandex is yellower the Rogues are
sexier and Jubilee is a main character
for some reason because what the x-men
really need is a mall red with a power
of sparkles stop trying to make Jubilee
happen show it's not gonna happen
return to the mid-90s on Fox where in
between reruns of eight the cat and
Power Rangers you'd watch the x-men
bring classic storylines to life mission
accomplished money okay like the Phoenix
saga that was so much better than x3
Days of Future past that's as good as
Days of Future past and a Weapon X
episode that's so much better than
Wolverine Origins you'll almost give
them a pass for the half a season five
where they moved production to the
Philippines to get the other half of the
crystal is locks right into Magnus's
fortress yeesh
don't get any ideas singer prepare for a
series that's about so much more than
fighting supervillains it's also about
fighting prejudice
our mutants as racists and bigots of all
stripes are defeated by a stereotypical
southerner well Andrews out colder a
leftover Westbrook stereotypical Cajun
there's always more Gators in the pile
stereotypical Russian da svidaniya and
stereotypical German of cost by line
because nothing to be stereotypes like a
different more powerful stereotype so
gear up for this 90s cartoon that's
great despite being very much a product
of its time she rendered mutant of
course not
makin Kathy that might be the second
best superhero series ever made and when
first place is Batman second place ain't
half bad
starring Sentinels sucking at their jobs
I am still windy storm yelling at nature
the Arctic winds awesome Easter eggs
his name is cable
Wolverine trying to curse all right.you
egg-sucking piece of gutter trash
he said alien gutter trash cliffhangers
Wolverine grunting
ah
Scott and gene yelling each other's
names gene gene and gene graze ex-gays
ohms is it weird that this is kind of
turning me on x-men better than the
movies
you know the only thing better than the
intro the Japanese intro
Sugoi be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers it's not just a phase
dad sometimes when I close my eyes I
can't see
I hope they cast Rob Schneider as cable
hold the door hold the door Hodor I like
shorts they're comfy and easy to wear